yeah hello and welcome to this video I
still have two somewhat getting used to
the recording software doing this in OBS
which I have of course used in streaming
but one thing that is still irritating
me is said that you press like record
locally and it just like starts I mean
it's not even there's no delay
whatsoever and it's also um it's also um
you don't really see em like no red
button or something where is it okay I'm
recording I mean of course you know you
should be recording because you press
record okay anyhow let's play amorous
coves I had a very similar opening just
there were just some games ago trying to
trap this night which is at the moment I
think a threat with chief war this
particular move order with Knight g4
allows me to not play Knight c3 but
rather this setup that controls d4 which
I mean it's probably not the end of the
world for black but it is quite an
interesting twist you know it's not a
move that black will play in a happy
state of mind because when you play h5
you know that f6 is not going to be that
easily played I mean it's not totally
impossible but it weakens our walking
cell structure a lot it's not so
terrible because there is no light
squared bishop so as usual if you play
like f6 here you would like Oh g6 is a
weak but yeah and I don't have a bishop
1.e4 or c2 or anything like that so it's
not as some critical yeah
he is stopping g4 okay my idea here is a
simple night to e3 trade the night plane
until it wind ah4 one hits it's just as
simple as that
and I wonder here Bishop d5 could be his
intention I mean could be a Sam is of
course wrong and that is his intention
so what to do I don't like to play c4 in
this particular moment when 94 is
certainly about an option even though I
can't a cage for in that case hmm
it looks a bit odd I know but I have not
see to to cover d4 and it makes this
bishop on e6 look entirely stupid I
still have the 92 ideas and it's close
to again winning the pawn down okay this
is useful anyway
maybe I'm too much focused on winning
that porn I'm not sure
but it seems a very straightforward way
of playing and I don't really see him
[Music]
why I shouldn't do it yeah if I don't
know I could go a for myself I mean
let's just stop that just stop him
playing on that side of the board
yeah but yeah I was thinking it's not a
big deal I am I'm also attacking a five
the the whole time
even simple rupee 1 is coming into
consideration like a rupee 1 if he goes
back a route to g8 I have looked B 3 and
then I'm starting to double on the B
file myself now I'm probably maybe not
threatening to take take a 5 a d3
is still hanging it so it's a bit
complicated you know there are multiple
pawn weaknesses in play like his pawns
there a week but d3 is also a bit weak
okay so it takes a look at each 5
yeah shall I do that now I mean I was
after this idea the whole time
I mean if he takes now Queen takes I'm
even just attacking see 5 + H 4 is still
hanging and 94 I'm taking and draw back
to see - it should also the pen should
also be fine here there is the
additional point of route b5 which
however no he cannot play Bishop d7 that
makes it a bit more interesting even
Bishop design fails to g6 so maybe maybe
this is an idea now that he stumbled
into it
I always was some annoying pressure I
mean that was a blunder but it was a bit
a bit annoying for him the whole time
okay so let's have a brief analysis over
this game it wasn't such a long game
yeah he and Knight d5 is usually
believed to be the main move and I
believe to be as a weird way to put it
is the main move here which is a similar
thing but here I'm committed to the
knight on c3 in this particular
situation I also have this option to
play with c3 which I had a look at in my
efore repertoire lefm that was an
interesting way to play and I think my
position here was quite okay at least I
liked it c3 Queen and he he went to h5
here is a certain name I don't know I
don't like it to be honest the engine
here gives f6 and even wants to go a g5
and h5 yeah this is an interesting way
and like h3g fire ferrets fearless play
interesting it's really interesting I
mean
yeah you can probably do it yeah I have
no LightSquared bishop and my whole
setup here is not especially dynamic no
the night cannot go here anymore
yeah that looks a lot better than age 5
in my evo repertoire that I released
there was it was a little bit different
because I was analyzing actually this
line which can amount to the same thing
that we call in the game but it was a
slightly different move water I think I
don't quite remember exactly okay in the
game you went age 5 which makes all
those advances a bit more difficult to
do and here after this I really feel
like I'm better and now the engine gives
queenie 292 makes sense
and probably this isn't isn't terrible
either it would be surprised if I would
be in trouble or anything this is a
position where I think white some edge
should be rather long term because h4
will be eternally weak in some way and
you don't really see much the black can
do about it now b5 385 a for heads also
what the computer wants to do and now
the capture I think they're keeping the
tension looks looks a bit better would
be one year why not
85 is weak and here 93 yeah this I
actually felt it was a debatable
decision back when Queen c3m Queen a3
this is certainly also making a lot of
sense but I think I should be fine here
oh I'm not flying what it is very
surprising to me
but I shouldn't be in good shape here
that's crazy why am I not in good shape
so 94 take sticks let's see - Oh a
blunder t5 way that's a very good reason
why it's a very good reason
oops yeah that's a big boobs it's
embarrassing
I should not blunder the biggest pond
what okay after see five rupee fire
everything's cool any blunder I mean the
position is better anyway with that
helped not Wow
so that means Knight III really was bad
yeah if you can't go 94 without any
problem that this move was just bad
okay Queen c3 I mean it's pretty clear
I'm a just keep the structure I should
be in good shape but still I'm really
surprised back simply blunder d5 in that
line okay I hope you enjoyed the game
thanks for watching